Mattson: So while
my presentation
is getting up onscreen,
I'll just do a little
introduction.
My name is Justin Mattson.
I'm a developer advocate
here at Google
working on Android.
And up front,
I just want
to thank you all
for your interest
in Android
and letting me be here
and do all the cool stuff
that I--
that I get to do.
And, so a couple
of months ago,
my manager said to me,
"Hey, do you want to give
a presentation at Google I/O?"
And I said,
"Yeah, that'd be great!
What's the title?"
And he said, "'Debugging Arts
of the Ninja Masters.'"
And I thought, "All right,
no pressure there."
[chuckles]
And...so...
for today,
this is our agenda.
And debugging is in the title
of my presentation,
but I assume
that everyone here
has an idea of how to do
basic debugging,
stepping through code
and such like that.
So that's not what
I'm going to cover.
I'm going to cover
tools that you can use
to diagnose and solve
some of the more subtle
debugging issues
that you may encounter.
And one of these that
I'm going to focus
a fair deal on
is performance,
because poor performance
is a bug.
No one plans for this.
No user wants it.
No developer intends it.
So today,
we're gonna start out
with what I'm calling
the Tool Tour
of three tools
from the Android SDK
that you may or may not
be familiar with.
Even if you are
experienced with them,
I think you may
find some things here
that you didn't
know were there.
I certainly discovered
a couple of things
in the process
of creating content
for this session
that I wasn't aware of.
And after that,
I'm gonna go on
to some real-world usage
of these tools
in situations
that I've encountered.
And I think that'll be
a little--
the more interesting part
of the presentation.
And after being on the spot
for 45 or 50 minutes,
I think it's only fair
to turn the tables around
and put you guys
on the spot
for a little pop quiz
to see if you can
find the bugs
or find where to start
looking for the bugs.
And then, fair is fair,
so a pop quiz for me:
Q&A.
We've got a lot to cover,
so let's get started.
I'm gonna start out
talking about logcat.
And some of you
may be thinking,
"Well, why are you
talking about logcat?
This is a pretty
basic tool."
But I can't
emphasize enough
how important I think
using logcat
during your development is.
It's--it's really a tool
that provides you
some insight into what's
happening in the system.
And if you use it with
your programs properly,
it'll give you
an overall picture
of how your program execution
is going.
This dialogue is probably
the most dreaded
on the Android platform.
Your--your app has crashed.
And unfortunately,
this dialogue provides
very other--very little
other information
to you or the user
why this has happened.
So the first place
to start looking
is actually logcat.
And in logcat you'll often see
an error message like this.
In this case,
I happen to be doing something
incredibly silly
with the URI
that I was trying to fetch.
But beyond providing you
just the--
the forensic information
of what went wrong,
logcat
you can also think of
as your newsfeed
into the system.
So it's going to provide you
with the information
about your application,
if you choose to put it there--
and I encourage you to do so--
about other applications
that have
intelligently decided
to put information there,
and finally,
about the system state
that may impact
the execution of your program.
This is a slide
that I actually
didn't have time to take out,
but we don't
have time to cover.
So...
[laughs]
Here's a simple
piece of code
that I want to use
to illustrate
how logcat can be helpful.
It--I'm basically
reading URL here.
So I'm starting
a new HTTP client.
I'm getting the content
of the response,
and then I'm reading it
and just discarding it.
Now, I never really
expect to encounter
any of either of these
two exceptions
under the assumptions
that, one,
my network connection
on my device is up,
and, two,
my server is up.
So let's just
take those for granted.
In this case,
I, you know,
I tested the code
100 times on the emulator.
It worked perfectly
every time.
And so then it was time
to put it onto a device.
When I put it on the device
and looked at logcat,
this is what I saw.
Exactly what
I didn't expect.
I'd gotten an I/O exception.
Now, my personal
first reaction
is to overreact
and start looking at my code
and trying to figure out
what I've done wrong.
Luckily, this time,
I decided not to do that
and instead look back
in logcat to see this message
relating to the Wi-Fi service
which had kicked in.
And what had
actually happened here
was that my device was asleep
before I started running.
I started running my program,
and in the process,
Wi-Fi woke up and associated
with an axis point
that it knew
and that it connected to.
Well, the problem is that,
of course,
all your sockets
are going to break.
You can't fail over
from the cellular network
onto this Wi-Fi network
that--that, you know,
T-Mobile or Vodafone
has no idea about.
So logcat in this case
was my newsfeed looking in.
And the system told me
this change has happened,
and the resulting...
the result was affecting
my program in a way
that I'd never expected.
So I didn't spend forever
trying to chase after
a problem that didn't exist.
Just deal with it.
Next to the dialogue
that your application
has crashed,
I would say
this is the second--
the second-worst dialogue
to see on the Android.
And this goes a little back
to what I was saying:
that no one designs
for poor performance.
Users don't like
to wait for things.
And, really,
I don't think
that they should have to.
So, again, the first place
that I started
diagnosing this problem
was to go to logcat.
And in there, I saw this,
which was rather suspicious.
Lots of garbage collection,
all going on
in a single process,
which, in this case,
turned out to be my process.
And--
so just keep this in mind.
I'm gonna go deeper
into this example
later in the presentation.
So, like I said,
logcat is a newsfeed,
and it's full of information.
Sometimes, it's full
of way too much information.
So one of the ways
that you can cut through
the jungle of messages
that you see in logcat
is with filters
that you can supply
to the program.
You simply specify the filter
as the tag,
and then, colon,
the severity.
And the tag is whatever
you specify in your code.
And the severity is whatever
severity level
you put it at.
I'll note that this
ordering of tag and severity
is actually reversed
from the way it's presented
in logcat,
which prevent--
which presents severity,
and then--
severity and--
severity, slash, the tag.
Another note is that,
when you specify severity
this way,
you're going to get
everything
that's above this threshold
that you specify.
So if you specify "warning,"
you'll get errors
and warnings.
In order to make
best use both--
in order to make best use
of the messages
that you're putting out
from your program,
use a strategy
that I like to call
smart tagging.
So for any reasonably complex
Android program,
you're going to have
different logical components.
Maybe you have one component
that deals with
your data model,
and another component
that deals with
synchronizing
your web service.
It doesn't make sense
to tag all your log messages
from your program
the same thing.
Because then they're
not going to be meaningful.
But you also want
to make these tags related
in a way that can be expressed
in a regular expression,
so that you can
do easy filtering
and get all the messages
from--
all the messages
related to your program,
or, you know,
if you want,
then you can go down
and drill into the specific
component.
Now, like I've said,
logcat has a lot
of information in it.
And it can be tempting
to generate spam.
So I encourage you,
when you're considering
what to put in logcat,
to be precise.
So log just what you need--
events that are interesting,
not every event
that comes along
and you're--you're unlikely
to ever be concerned with.
Be concise in that--
print out something
that encapsulates
exactly what's happened
in the least
possible information.
I've seen several instances
in logcat
where the information
printed out
is an entire email
or an entire web page
that's loaded.
And that's not going
to actually be useful
to very many people.
And finally, because logcat
is a shared medium,
and everyone
has access to it,
be privacy sensitive.
Don't print out
passwords
or credit card numbers
or authentication tokens,
which is also stuff
that I've, you know,
seen in log messages
before.
You don't want to be
the source of a privacy leak.
So...in summary,
you know,
logcat is a basic tool,
but it provides you
a lot of power.
And I don't think anyone's
above looking at logcat
and the information that it--
that it can give you.
After logcat
is TraceView.
And TraceView gives you
a graphical representation
to look at your performance
profiling data
that's really powerful.
So when you're tracing
your program in Android,
it's going to record
every method and function
entry and exit point.
It's going to record,
you know,
when these events happened,
and therefore,
how long execution took.
And then TraceView
will provide you
a timeline and a call tree
that you can navigate through
to easily figure out,
you know,
which methods are being called,
in which order,
and from
which other methods.
It's really a must,
I think,
to use TraceView
for any developer
that's serious
about performance.
And I think we should
all be serious about it.
I'm going to go over
some examples of this later,
but sometimes you may think,
"Oh, I'm not doing
anything in my code
"that has a significant
performance impact.
You know, it's--
it's just plain code."
But there are some
innocuous-looking calls
out there that turn out to be
not so innocuous-looking.
And they're really easy
to spot in TraceView.
It's a very powerful tool.
And, you know,
take advantage
of the power that's
afforded by it.
And finally, because
code is never fast enough.
We've seen this
many places
in many products
around Google--
when we make products
faster,
we make the latency lower,
usage increases.
People like speed.
So starting tracing
in your application
is actually really simple.
You have two options.
You can start it in code.
So here you just call
Debug.startMethodTracing.
And then stopMethodTracing
when you're done.
I'll note that there
are separate calls
for tracing dalvik code
versus native code.
So here in the top example,
I'm just tracing
dalvik code.
And then you can also start it
from the command line.
The disadvantage there
being that it's
a less granular experience.
If you want to trace
just a small section in code,
then you really want
to start and stop method tracing
in the code.
But, of course, the advantage
of the command line
is you don't have to modify
the actual source
and then remember to take
that debugging code out.
And so these commands
will control debugging
for the entire
virtual machine.
And by that, I mean
remember that, in Android,
each process has its own
virtual machine
that it executes within.
So you're not starting it
just for an activity
or just for a service where--
where you call this.
You're starting it
for your entire process.
As a result, you're gonna
generate a lot of information
really quickly.
And to help deal with that,
just trace what you need.
And finally,
like I mentioned,
tracing has a big impact
on performance,
and that's why you want
to remember
to take any--
any debug--or...
Any time you start
tracing in your code,
you want to make sure
to take that out
before you ship.
Because performance
is going to be
multiple times slower
while tracing is running,
simply because the system
is gathering
a lot of information.
So, for example,
in this time
when I was tracing,
and I'm tracing over about
20 mil--
or 20 seconds here,
so 20,000 milliseconds,
I think this trace file
was around eight megabytes.
So data accumulates
very rapidly.
And this is the top part
of TraceView,
the--the execution timeline.
So along the left,
you have the threads
that are executing.
And, like, I said,
along the top,
the time that they're
executing in.
TraceView also gives you
the ability
to look
at individual methods
and where their--
what their parents
and children are.
And navigate quickly
through the--
through the call graph,
because when you identify
a performance problem,
it may be with a,
you know,
a method that you've
never heard of.
So you need to figure out
where in your code
this is being called.
You'll also note that
the methods are enumerated.
So they're enumerated
in the order
that they're
originally called.
So thread.run,
not surprisingly,
is really the first method
that's called here.
And they're
also color-coded.
These color codes
will correspond
to colors
in the execution timeline.
You can note the--
the big, green blob
on thread 14 there
that we'll actually
talk about a little later.
A quick note about
some of the statistics
that are provided.
Most of them
are pretty obvious.
I just want to make sure
it's clear
what inclusive and exclusive
execution time mean.
So inclusive execution time
is all the time spent
executing a method,
plus its children.
And exclusive is simply
the time spent
executing code that exists
solely in that method,
and not counting any time
from descendent methods
that are called.
So like I said, the--
the source
of your performance issue
may not actually
be in your code,
but it may
be somewhere else.
And to get to the bottom
or to the top of that,
tracing through
the call tree
can be very useful.
So I'm just gonna show
a quick example here.
So you can click
on the down arrow there
and see where
this method was called from.
It's called from
FetchURL.
Go up further to parents.
And I could also then,
you know,
go into--go and navigate
down the call tree
into any of the children.
TraceView is a really
powerful tool,
and it--it affords us
the ability
to optimize reality.
I myself have spent
plenty of time over my career
agonizing and designing
really complex
data structures,
only to find out in the end
that this data structure
is used
in less than 1%
of execution time.
So I encourage you
to take advantage of TraceView,
and therefore,
you can design sensibly,
build a proof of concept,
test,
and then figure out
if you need to spend
hours and hours developing
a wonderfully elegant,
highly-efficient
data structure.
So TraceView will help you
look at, you know,
the execution code
of your program.
But another big component
of Android applications
is the UI.
And the UI can easily
get more complex
than you might imagine.
And HierarchyViewer
is one way
that you can deal with
identifying this complexity,
and once you've identified it,
look at solving it.
HierarchyViewer gives you
a graphical depiction
of the UI tree from the--
from the point of view
of the layout system.
And so we're going
to navigate this tree
a little now.
Each note in the tree
can be double-clicked on.
And when you
double-click on that,
it's going
to show you the UI
represented
by that sub tree.
And you can see it
on black or white backgrounds.
Notice that this UI element
has a black background
native to it.
I can look through, further,
the UI tree here,
go down to see
some of the children,
and then maybe click on
another child node over here.
And again, investigate--
you know,
does this element
have a background to it?
As it turns out,
this has no background,
or it's transparent.
In addition,
HierarchyViewer
will show you lots
of information
about any individual node
in the tree.
So here you can look
at all the properties
as well as many
of the responses
from essentially
the getter methods of--
of that view.
And then, because hierarchies
are often large,
down in
the bottom corner there
you can see a zoomed-out view
of the entire UI tree.
When you're looking
at HierarchyViewer,
there are a couple of classes
of conditions
that I often see
and can indicate that
optimization is--is possible
and, you know, recommended.
So the first group
I want to talk about
is infertile--what I call
infertile parents.
So this is a layout
or a view group
that has no parents
or a single parent.
You know, why do I need
a linear layout
that has as single child
that is a linear layout?
Did I say a single parent?
I mean a single child.
So why do I need
a linear layout
that has a single child
that's also a linear layout,
that's a relative layout.
The answer
is that I don't.
So, you know, this is ripe
for optimization here.
The other set is something
that I call clones.
And so this is parents
that have children
that are the same type
that they are,
or have children
where the children
are the same type.
So an example again
would be, you know,
a linear layout parent
that has two
linear layout children.
There's probably a way
to combine these
or to convert them either
to a relative layout
or a table layout.
And then the other example
I was talking about,
if you have some layout
that has two
relative layout children,
well, relative layout
siblings
are very uncommon
to be necessary,
because the data
is inherently related.
These conditions sometimes
result from...
having our layout broken
into multiple pieces,
which is sensible
from a design and--
and coding perspective.
It makes dealing
with the UI simpler.
It keeps the layout files,
on average, smaller.
The problem is that then
we usually put a--
put a view group,
so some kind of layout,
as the parent of this
component of the UI.
And then, when you
plug it into your UI,
you get this container
that you didn't really need--
you just put there
so that you could build
this--this file
that you were just going
to incorporate
into your UI.
And the answer to this
is to use the merge tag.
The merge tag
is a placeholder layout
that says, "Whatever
my children are,
"just inject them
directly into
whatever view group
I'm being included in."
So the merge tag
essentially goes away
when you
include this layout
into another one.
Okay, so enough of talking
about tools.
Let's see
some usage of this.
And so looking at code,
you know,
is kind of like
traveling along
and visiting
different towns.
And so, in my travels,
I've accumulated some tales.
And the first one
that I'm --
I'm going to call Betrayal,
which is nice and kind of,
you know,
ooh, intrigue.
It is kind of intriguing.
Anyway, so the first
couple examples here
are gonna come from
when I was looking
at the Google Finance
application.
So that's Google's finance
client for Android,
which now includes
all these improvements.
And what I was really
focusing on
was trying to optimize
start-up time.
Because the app
start-up time
wasn't as good
as we wanted it to be.
And start-up time
is particularly important
because this
is the first experience
your users will ever have
with your application.
And they may decide
at that point
never to use it again.
But, beyond that,
it's also the first experience
they have
when they decide they want
to start a new session
with your app.
When they haven't opened it
for two days,
and they open it again
and they go,
"Ohh, I'm opening
this slow app again."
So anyways,
this first impression
needs to be snappy.
So when I started
looking at the performance
and tracing in finance,
this is--this is
the execution graph
that I saw.
And immediately, I see
this big blob of color,
and I think,
"Wow, what is that?"
And furthermore,
why is that running
on the UI thread?
So you can see it's on
the thread that's labeled Main.
So this is the UI thread,
which always
needs to be responsive.
Something's running
for two seconds on there,
blocking the UI thread.
And it suddenly
made sense to me why,
when I was using Finance,
I was frustrated
at the start-up.
And the only thing
I could think
that could take that long
was that with some--
someone had done
a network request,
and forgotten to move it off
to its own thread.
I was then very surprised
to discover
that this had nothing to do
with a network request,
and that the method
that was being shown there
is something called
getTimeZonesNative.
And I thought...
well, one, why is this
taking so long?
But then, I'm not doing
anything with time zones.
Why is this even being called
in my code?
Well, luckily, TraceView
will provide an answer for me.
So I can trace up
and I see some more stuff
about time zones,
and then something
about date formats.
And further up...
further up, more stuff
about date formats.
And finally, I get into
my own code.
So, all right, something
about date formatting
for my own code.
Where's this coming from?
So it was time for me
to look at the code.
And, as it turns out,
in the Finance UI,
there's a little timestamp
in the top right of the UI
that denoted the last time
that data had been loaded
from the server.
And to create this
little timestamp
we were calling
dateformat.format,
a seemingly
very innocuous call
that really shouldn't
take very long at all,
should just happen
right away.
As it turns out,
it takes about two seconds
to run.
And this is what
was blocking the UI thread.
So the story
has a happy ending.
The solution was just,
you know,
move the call
to its own thread,
and also, because
I didn't think this was
a very important part
of the UI,
make it less important.
Let other stuff go first.
And the result was much better
perceived start-up time.
Because now--and I say
"perceived start-up time"
because I'm not actually
avoiding any execution here.
I'm still doing everything.
But I'm putting it off,
and I'm also not letting it
interfere--
interfere with the UI.
And so, I mean,
in order to lower priority,
all you need to do
is set the priority
on the thread.
So the key take-aways
that I want to express here
are trust no one.
Just because you think
it's a safe call
that doesn't take very long
doesn't mean that it's
a safe library call
that doesn't take very long.
Talking to--talking
to one of the engineers
that actually worked
on implementing this,
what's happening as we're
loading this giant database
of--of, you know, every
date format ever known
off of a file somewhere
and pushing it up
into the Java layer.
And this is what's
taking two seconds.
And it's actually
two seconds in real time,
not debug time, because
this is a native method
that we're looking at.
Secondly, a little profiling
can go a long way.
No one had done profiling
on the Finance app.
But after
about five minutes,
you could see very easily
that there was a problem.
And finally,
that priority matters.
This little part
of the UI was secondary
to the user experience.
The most important part
of the user experience
was getting updated quotes
on the screen
as rapidly as possible.
It's nice to know
when they came from,
but it's more important
just to have them.
So traveling about,
it's best to find
the shortest point
from "A" to "B."
However, that's not always
the route we take.
So this next example
is also from Finance.
And now, it's, you know,
an obvious performance issue
in the execution timeline.
But that was really
the only one that, you know,
jumped out at me.
So after that,
it was time to go
into the method information
and see what I could learn
about what methods
were taking a long time
to execute.
So I started out
sorting by
exclusive execution time.
So again, this shows
just the time spent
executing lines of code
within an individual method.
And so that means
these are the methods
where your code
is spending most of--
or your program is spending
most of its lifetime.
And good targets
to look for
when you're looking
for inefficiencies here
are methods that have
a few calls,
because then you have
fewer code paths
to worry about making sure
that your changes
won't interfere with.
And ones that are
obviously a long running time,
because you want to get
the most bang for your buck.
And once you've identified
your targets,
see what you can do
about reducing or eliminating
the use of them.
So this is what I saw.
And you can see my friend
up there at the top:
get TimeZonesNative.
It's still there.
And there are
a bunch of methods
that really can't
be avoided,
probably string.charAt
and JSONTokenizer.
This is all necessary.
But going down further,
I see bitmap.nativecompress,
and I go, "Hmm."
Well, this is only called,
it looks like, twice,
and it's fairly expensive,
because sorted by this,
it's like
number eight or ten.
Something like that.
So let's see what's
going on with this method.
And before
I jumped into the code,
I decided, take
a look around in TraceView.
Use TraceView
to let me tell--
use TraceView in order
to learn what's happening
before I jump
into this code base
that's relatively
foreign to me.
So to do this...
start out and make sure
that I'm zoomed in
on the right method there.
So bitmap.nativecompress.
And then I'm gonna go
and see who calls this thing.
Because I don't really know
where the call comes from.
So I go up, and we're
adding something to the cache.
And more information
about adding to the cache.
And this is coming
from result available,
from a call to get
a news item or get a chart.
Okay, so I have
a general idea
of what the progression
is here.
And then, I'm gonna zoom in
on the timeline
here in TraceView.
Make sure I'm centered
on the right function again.
And so this is gonna
expand out the timeline for me.
And then I can look
and see what's being executed
before and after.
I'm gonna look
at the "before" first.
So I'll move it over
so we can see
the method name.
And there's a call
at the top.
You can see
the bitmap factory,
that native decode string.
This series of events
immediately strikes me
as a bit odd.
Because it looks like
what's happening
is I'm decoding a bitmap,
and then I'm encoding
a bitmap.
And I thought, "Okay,
and this is also around
"network fetching.
"Am I converting images--
image sizes on the client?
If so, we really
need to fix that."
It turns that the answer's
not quite that.
So I dove into the code,
and this is kind of
what I found.
It's taking the long way
to go from one point
to the other.
So what's happening
is I'm downloading a response
and parsing out the data.
Part of that parsing
is to create a bitmap
that I'm gonna
display onscreen.
So for a quote or something.
Also gonna display
the other quote information.
Then what's happening
is I'm compressing
my onscreen bitmap
so that I can add it
to the cache.
Now, it's a roundabout way,
but you can easily see
how you'd get here.
You start out
and build an application,
and then you think,
"Okay, we're gonna
display the data onscreen."
And a little later,
you think,
"Wait, we should
cache this data,
"so we don't have to
download it every single time.
Okay, we'll cache the data
that's onscreen."
And so you end up going
much further
and through many more
lines of code
than are necessary,
when the better thing to do
is to take a step back,
evaluate how the code
is operating,
and implement
this little fix--
which is read the response,
take the image data--
which is
in the same format
that we were
caching anyways--
take the image data
and cache it first.
And then,
from that image data,
inflate your bitmap
that you're gonna
put onscreen.
And then, you know,
you can go ahead
and discard the--
the base image data,
'cause you no longer
need it.
So the effect of this
looks fairly small.
I reduced about 2%
of start-up time.
But again,
this is debug time,
and this
is a native method.
So it's--
it resulted in a--
a larger real-time
improvement.
The key take-aways here
are big is beautiful.
Go for the target--
go for the largest
targets first.
It's the most bang
for the buck and where--
where you'll get furthest
with your effort.
Before leaping
into the code,
especially if it's
a foreign code base,
like this was for me,
use what TraceView
affords you
and look at where
the calls are coming from
and also what's executing
around the call
that you're interested in,
both on the same thread
and on different threads,
if you need to use that
to get an idea
of what's happening.
And finally, three rights
can make a left.
Iterative development
can lead us places
that we didn't
expect to go.
And it's--
it's always a good idea
to take a step back
occasionally
and see if there's
a shorter path.
So the next little tale
I'm going to call
"Packing Mistakes."
So sometimes when we're--
when we're going about
on our travels,
we repack our suitcase
and some things
don't get ordered
the way
we expected them to.
And I started out looking--
looking for a problem.
I had sorted by
exclusive execution.
I've--I'd seen what was
in the execution timeline,
so now I'm gonna sort
by inclusive.
So this will identify--
this will sort by
the most expensive methods,
the most expensive
methods
in total time
for the system.
And this amounts
to something like
a breadth-first traversal
of your call tree.
So you can imagine
if you have a tree
outlining all the calls
that are made,
the most expensive ones
are going to be at the top.
The parents will always be
greater than their children.
It's not precisely
what it is,
but it's along those lines.
So in this case, again,
I'm gonna sort
by inclusive execution.
And I'll see some stuff
that I really can't avoid
related to strings
and the system and whatnot.
And then
there are some things
that maybe I can't avoid,
but there are lots of calls.
And I want
to look for something
that only has a few calls.
So luckily, I see
this GetNewsItemsJSON,
which only has one call,
and it's taking
a lot of my time.
So what's--what's making
up the time
in this method?
Okay, so I'm fetching
something from the network,
and it's talking about
a result being available,
which is great because
I'm kind of already
familiar with this code.
So I can click down.
And see who else's method
is calling.
So again, it's something
about adding an item
to the cache.
And this is called
from a network fetch.
And I noticed this callback
result--
result available
from the network fetch.
So at this point,
I have a rough idea
of what's going on.
I'm fetching something
from the network
on one thread,
so I've probably got kind of
a network worker thread going.
And once I've got that,
I call some callback method
that's resulting
in the data being added
to the cache.
And taking a look
at the code,
this is more or less
what I found.
So what I've got
is I'm starting a new array,
which is going to be
my list
of processed
or downloaded items.
And then I've got a list
called source
that I'm reading.
So I'm downloading
each of these items,
one at a time,
then adding them to the list
of things
that's been downloaded.
And then I'm doing
a callback on them to say,
"Okay, your data's ready.
Do whatever you want
with it."
In this case, it's gonna be
added to the cache.
What immediately strikes me
as odd, though,
is that I'm adding
the items
that have been downloaded
to a list.
And I'm
processing this list
each time I'm downloading
an item.
Meaning the first item
in the list
is going to be
processed "N" times,
if there are "N" items
in the list.
And the second one,
"N" minus one,
and et cetera, et cetera.
So this seems wrong.
It's possible
there's a scenario
where this is right.
But it seems odd.
And I look back
over the code,
and, indeed,
this was odd
and a mistake
that was added
when the exception handling
code was refactored.
So the simple fix
is to move this
outside of the fetch loop
and have it run after.
So obviously, this results
in fewer calls
to the callback methods.
And it decreased
start-up time by about 5%.
And this time,
it's really about 5%.
And--oh, wrong way.
So this, you know, this story
taken with the others,
I just want to say
that there's no single angle
of attack in looking at--
looking at problems
you may be experiencing
with your code.
There are multiple angles,
certainly,
from the performance
perspective,
and they're all valuable.
And also that, sometimes,
when you're...
looking to improve
your performance,
you discover things--
other things along the way.
In this instance,
this bug wasn't causing
a crash in the program,
but what if I was now
suddenly fetching
100 news items
instead of the five or six?
And this callback was being
executed, you know,
that many times?
So it revealed a bug
that could have been
tomorrow's crash.
Next in
my traveler's tales is--
I'm going to talk about
consolidating containers.
So when you're traveling,
sometimes you end up
with a lot of little suitcases,
and it's time to turn them
into one big one.
And so we're gonna
look at HierarchyViewer here
and analyzing a UI
that's become overly complex.
And I just want to say again
that UI is code too.
We often
don't think of it that way
because it's specified
in Android and XML.
But it is on the same level
as the Java code
that we're writing
for the platform.
This is a little bit
of the UI
from the Google
Scoreboard application
that I was looking at,
and it seems pretty simple.
I've got two rows of data,
and then
some other data
on the--
on the left-hand side.
Or, I'm sorry,
on the right-hand side.
It's not quite in rows.
So it turns out this has
a rather complex view tree.
And...it doesn't seem
like it really needs to.
And you can see a couple
of the cases
that I was talking about
here before,
where I've got,
you know, clones
where a linear layout
has a linear layout
that has a child or, you know,
infertile parents.
And, looking at this data,
I thought,
"Surely this can be turned
into a relative layout.
Surely this can be made
less complex."
The first step to doing that
is defining
the relationships that--
that exist in the UI
between the data.
And I have to give
a proviso on this slide.
It was having lots of fun
with keynote transitions.
So I used as many
of the cool ones as I could.
So just bear with me.
So the first--the element
that I'm gonna start with
is in the top left.
And there's nothing here,
because we're looking
at a baseball score.
But if this were something
like tennis,
there would be
a player ranking
or something like that
there.
So I'm gonna define
this little piece of the UI
simply to align
with the left-hand side
and the top of its container.
That's its relationship
to the container.
My first fun transition.
And then the team name
is going--
its relationship
to this area
is that it's
to the right of it,
and also aligned with the top
of its container.
So to be part
of this top row.
Now, the next UI element
is actually
not strictly related
to the team name.
It is the score
for the team,
but this is actually
related to data
for the game.
And it's an important,
you know,
little distinction
about this UI,
that the right-hand side
is concerned with the game
and the left-hand side
is concerned
with the team itself.
So this is specified
as being related
to the top
of the container again,
but this time, it's related
to the right-hand side
of its container instead
of the left-hand side,
with a generous
padding margin
to allow room for other--
other elements.
And along the bottom here,
you can see
this is pretty similar,
with cool transitions.
But something I'll note
is that
I've specified
the second row.
I want to make sure
that it is horizontally
aligned with the top row.
So I've added
other specifications
to make sure that
the left-hand boundaries
of the UI elements
are aligned.
More stuff
that you'd expect.
And then, like I said,
this data
on the right-hand side
is really related
to the game itself,
and not the team.
So this score stat--
or the score detail area,
which is, you know,
who's on base,
is now defined
in a relationship
to the score status,
which is what inning we're in
and the count.
So now that I've defined
all these relationships,
I can go and codify this
in XML.
And the great thing is
that I went from a hierarchy
that looks like this--
it's five levels deep--
to a hierarchy
that looks like this.
One level deep...
in terms of HierarchyViewer,
something
that's just beautiful.
And...
now, you may
be asking why.
It looks the same now
as it did before.
So what's the difference?
Who cares?
Well, design
flatter hierarchies
for what I call
aerodynamic performance.
The UI will draw faster.
In this case,
the drawing, I think,
improved by around 7%.
And also, RelativeLayouts,
when you can use them,
have a lot of other
ancillary benefits.
One, they adapt better
to their environment.
As the container,
you know,
as the container grows
for these UI elements,
the elements
inside the UI
will just
automatically adapt.
And secondly,
using RelativeLayout
really makes you think about:
What are the relationships
in my data?
How is my UI related?
You know, where do these
pieces of data belong?
And it's a great, you know,
and useful exercise
to go through that.
So key takeaways:
Layouts are code too,
and they evolve and are
subject to all the same
necessarily rethinks
as other code.
And also that LinearLayouts
are almost seductive,
in a way.
They're simple to visualize
and deal with.
But they're also overused,
and I think we at Google have
to take some responsibility
for this, actually.
Almost all of our examples
are written
with LinearLayouts,
and we should probably
change that to encourage
developers to use
other layouts.
And finally, because
layouts are code,
they're going
to get overgrown.
They're going to evolve
and kind of turn into
mutant monsters sometimes.
So take a minute
to tame them.
Finally, I want to go back
to something
from earlier
in the presentation.
I'm gonna label it
"squeaky wheels" this time.
So if something's being noisy
in logcat,
there might be
a good reason for it,
and there might be something
that needs to be fixed.
So this was for some code
that I was using...
for an internal little
toy application
that I was writing.
And it was taking
much longer than I expected.
And I found out
that it was mostly due
to garbage collection.
To my rescue came a part
of DDMS
that you can use
in the stand-alone version
called Allocation Tracker.
So it does very much
what it--
what the name indicates.
It will track
memory allocations
and tell you
where they came from.
Just select your process
in the left-hand side of DDMS,
which is not shown here.
And then click
"start tracking."
And then get allocations
when you want to look
at the allocations
that have been made.
And this is what I saw.
A bunch of allocations,
all from the exact,
same place in my program...
where I was reading
a URL.
And what I discovered
when I went back
and looked at my code
was that I was using code
that I'd imported
from another program.
A much simpler program,
very, very specific purpose.
And so what I'm doing here
is I'm--I'm opening a URL
and I'm reading it,
chunk by chunk--
in small chunks,
384 bytes.
And each time I read,
I add a little more
to my response buffer
that I'm reading.
So...
this was fine
for its original intent.
I was only intending
that this read
a couple kilobyte responses.
But it had outgrown
its usefulness in this case,
because I was reading
much larger ones.
The fixes, you know,
the fix was pretty simple.
First of all, I'm reading
much larger responses,
so try to read
in larger chunks.
Secondly, take
all the chunks together
and then assemble them
into one, full response
at the end,
and return that.
And the result was,
you know, my program
got quite a bit faster
because I wasn't
spending all this time
churning through memory.
And the key takeaway
that, you know,
key takeaways here
are that reused
or prototype code,
is great
for its purpose.
Leave yourself a to-do
in Eclipse
to change that later on.
And also, if you know
that your code
was only designed to operate
within certain tolerances,
use some log messages
or maybe even go as far
as throwing an exception
if the code is used on--
beyond its design tolerances.
And so those
are my traveler's tales,
and hopefully
a diverse tour
of the sorts of things
that you can do
with just a few
very powerful tools
in the Android SDK.
So I again encourage you
to exploit those tools heavily
to build better programs.
Now...I've been talking
for 47 minutes and 33 seconds.
So...pop quiz
for you guys.
So if you think you know
the answer,
we will dispense
with the microphones.
Just raise your hand
and I'll, you know, point.
I was looking at some code
that I'd written,
and I saw this.
Stack overflow error.
So very curious.
It sort of appeared
out of nowhere.
Couldn't figure out why.
And it went on
and on and on.
And so the question
is what's going on here?
Ideas?
So the suggestion
was the UI is too complex.
And this is indeed
the answer.
Now, I've only, you know,
this is a little bit
of a trick question,
because I didn't give you
direct tools
in this presentation to--
to figure this out.
But the first place
to start with with this
would have been
HierarchyViewer.
And this
is actually something
that many developers
have experienced
as we're making
the transition
from 1.1 to Cupcake,
is that we've changed
the UI layout code,
which can result in...
some view hierarchies
that were exceedingly deep...
no longer working
in Cupcake.
So the next quiz is...
let's say that I have
these two UIs.
And they look the same.
But they perform
somewhat differently.
You'll see that the list
on the left
is quickly outpacing
the list on the right.
And so the question is,
well, one, either,
"Where should I start
the investigation
of what's going on?"
Or two, directly,
you know,
"What's going on here?"
So let's start, you know,
"Where could I look
for the investigation?"
Yes?
So the questions was:
What kind of adapter
am I using
for my list view?
It happens to be
an array adapter here.
Sorry.
So the question
was about the images
for the thumbnails.
The images are actually
all the same.
And so there's no--
there's no overhead
for those, essentially.
man: How complicated
is list item layout?
Mattson: The question was
how complicated
is my list item layout.
It's not
that complicated.
I made it complicated enough
to give a nice differential
for this--
for this example.
But I can tell you
that the layout--
the layout is defined
in XML
and is identical
for the left and right.
Yep.
The question was
am I updating all the rows
instead of just
the visible,
and the answer is no.
Yeah?
Did I add some debugging code
and forget to take it out?
That's a really--
that's a really good guess.
But, no, actually.
It would actually
be much slower
if that were the case.
Yeah?
Question was
do I convert views?
And that's the answer: no.
In the right--
in the right-hand example,
I'm not using
Convert View.
I'm inflating a new view
each and every time
my adapter is called.
In the left-hand side,
I am converting the views.
And the result is that
the UI is 30% faster.
So, you know,
this is the solution.
A great place that this
would have become
pretty readily apparent
is in TraceView
in the
in the getView call.
The get view call would have
been taking a lot longer
on the left-hand side
than on the right-hand side.
That's the pop quizzes
that I have for you.
So let my pop quiz commence.
And I will preface this
by saying a couple of things.
One, if I--if I don't
know the answer,
I promise to furrow my brow
thoughtfully,
stroke my chin,
and get back to you.
Two, please
use the microphones.
And, three, you know,
if you want to start
talking amongst yourselves,
if you wouldn't mind just
taking that out in the hall
so others can hear
the answers to the questions.
man: Hi, can you use
those debugging tools
like TraceView
or HierarchyView
for marketplace apps?
Mattson: I'm sorry?
For marketplace apps?
man: Yes, apps,
user-downloaded
from the marketplace.
Mattson: Um...
so I think with Hierarchy--
So the answer
for HierarchyViewer is no.
I believe the answer
with TraceView is yes,
because you can turn on
debugging for the VM
from the command line.
But you may need--
although I guess I'm not
entirely sure,
because you may actually
need root access
to turn on debugging
from the command line.
What's that?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Mattson: Yeah.
So I guess I should say if--
if you have
a developer phone,
and you're using
HierarchyViewer
and you're downloading apps
that aren't forward locked,
then--then, yes,
you should be able to see it.
Yep.
man: Is there any penalty
for using the log?
So logcat,
all of the Log.e, Log.d.
Mattson: I mean, you know,
no method is free.
But the--
the overhead for the log
is fairly--
fairly minimal.
You know,
a lot of the impact
and reason I ask people
to be careful
in the information
that they're putting there
is that it stays
a meaningful
and useful resource
for people.
man: Is that something
you should remove
before releasing
production code?
Mattson:
That's up to you,
but it can be--
it can be useful
to have it out there
in production code,
I mean, in our
production devices.
The--you know, our logcat
messages are on there.
You might want
to call them down.
But, you know,
if you can convince a user
to install the SDK
and connect--
connect it to ADB,
you might get some
interesting information
about, you know, why
your program's not working.
man: Thanks.
Mattson: Yep.
Yep?
man: I've had some issues
with uncaught exceptions
in my app out in the wild.
And the problem
seems to be due
to intermittent
network activity.
Mattson: Okay.
man: I'd like
to reproduce that
in the Emulator,
and I was wondering
if you had any suggestions
on how I can bring
my interface up and down
in the Emulator
to reproduce networking
going down.
Mattson: Well, so,
I think, actually,
in the emulator
there are options
to do flakey connection mode,
essentially.
man: There's lag and speed.
There doesn't seem to be
any options for flakiness.
Mattson: I thought you could
specify packet loss.
So, let me...
let's talk after here,
and give me a chance to look
at the Emulator Man. pages,
because I thought there
was a way to do that, but...
man: Thank you.
Mattson: Yep.
man: I was won--
Mattson: Yeah.
man: I was wondering if--
I'm sorry.
Mattson: Sorry, I meant--
I saw a big--
so let's go over here first.
man: Yeah, question:
You mentioned applications
being used,
maybe beyond
what you intended them for
in conditions like that.
Mattson: Sure.
man: That might not happen
until after you've shipped it,
'cause you don't know
that's gonna happen.
What technique
should you use
to evaluate
that kind of thing
from a customer that might
call you and say,
"This thing
is running slow,"
and you're trying
to figure out
if it something
they're doing different.
Mattson: Well,
I mean, there's nothing
inherent to the system
that would allow you
to do that.
I mean, hopefully,
in this case,
your test cases
cover the usage scenarios.
Although obvious--
man: In this case,
it didn't, right?
Mattson: Right, obviously
that's not always strictly true.
You know,
so there's nothing
that I can recommend
from the platform.
The best recommendation
that I--I can give
is that, you know,
you may want to write out,
essentially,
a log file to the SD card.
And then...again, if you
can convince your customer
to connect
to their computer
and pull this log file off
and get access to it.
But, yeah, unfortunately,
there's nothing inherent
in the system.
man: Thank you.
Mattson: Yeah.
man: So my question was
if there are any plans
to add an ability
to Android
to post a stack trace
to the developer's email.
This is one
of the problems
that commercial apps have.
You deploy it,
you're really good,
but you miss something.
And you simply cannot
reproduce that problem.
So next to that "force close"
dialogue button,
there should be possibly
an option--
Mattson: Right, so basically,
automatic bug reporting
is--is addressed.
man: I guess not automatic,
just a user should
have the option to post it.
Mattson: Right, right.
So the answer is that
there are no specific plans
right now to do that.
It is a request that,
you know,
we get--we get a lot.
So--and I think,
you know,
bringing it up to us
and keeping it conscious
is the best way to do that.
So it's just a matter
of priorities.
Because...
you know, it seems like
a feature that would be useful.
There--there may be reasons
that I don't know
that it's not there,
or it may just be time
at this point.
So, I mean, it seems
like a reasonable request.
I'm actually gonna--
man: If I could just do
a follow-up to your question.
Mattson: Yeah.
man: A quick and easy
way to deal with that
is to use Thread.
UncaughtExceptionHandler.
Just catch the exception.
Post it to your server.
And you'll be able
to get it that way.
You can't use any of
the JavaMail stuff to mail it,
but you can post it
to your server.
Just make sure you call
the default
uncaught exception handler
when your
exception handler runs.
Mattson: Great, thanks.
Yeah.
man: Logcat
is available
for the native code also.
So similarly,
I wanted to know
if TraceView is also
available,
and someday
to debug in the native code.
Mattson: Yeah, so like
I mentioned before,
there are separate methods--
there are separate calls
to enable dalvik tracing
versus native tracing.
So if you go ahead
and turn on native tracing,
you'll see that
in TraceView too.
If that's all
the questions,
I'm done, with a minute
and 30 seconds left.
Thank you, everyone.
[applause]